cela fait trois ans et demi que donald
trump emmanuel macron échangent
régulièrement sur des sujets politiques
de premier plan et leur relation est on
peut dire assez spécial d'un côté le
président de la république semble à
chaque fois très chaleureux avec son
homologue américain on ne compte plus
les poignées de mains interminables les
échanges tactile qui ne semble pas
toujours spécialement plaire à donald
trump
les sourires complices bref toute une
panoplie d'aptitudes avenante auquel on
s'est peu à peu habitué d'un autre côté
et n'allez surtout pas croire tu
emmanuel macron souhaite s'attirer les
bonnes grâces de monsieur trump en se
montrant excessivement tendre avec ce
dernier
en réalité il sait très bien ce qu'il
fait cela fait même partie de sa
stratégie
ma poignée de main avec donald trump ce
n'est pas innocent ce n'est pas l'alpha
et l'oméga d'une politique mais un
moment de vérité
il faut montrer qu'on ne fera pas de
petites concessions même symbolique mais
ne rien surmédiatisé non plus donald
trump le président turc
le président russe sont dans une logique
de rapport de force
ce qui ne me dérange pas je ne crois pas
la diplomatie de l'invectivé public mais
dans mes dialogues bilatéraux
je ne laisse rien passer c'est comme
cela qu'on se fait respecter
et oui ce n'est pas parce que trump aime
faire des combats poids ni demain qu'on
va se laisser faire non plus
[Musique]
là on sent que le président américain
bath a tendance à l'agacer sans non plus
exagérer il n'hésite pas à rappeler qu'à
la base c'est quand même lui le plus
stylé c'est un type génial intelligent
fort
il aime me tenir la main les gens ne se
rendent pas compte
il adore me tenir la main c'est bien et
ce côté tu es bien gentil mais causent
toujours on a pu le retrouver chez
donald trump tout au long de son mandat
le fameux mail planes and rise again
prononcé par emmanuel macron lors des
accords de paris desquels donald trump
s'est retirée a entraîné une autre
plaque du locataire de la maison blanche
voilà ce que ce dernier a déclaré à
propos de voitures brûlées la nuit de la
saint sylvestre à paris
comment va l'accord de paris pas la
peine de poser la question donald trump
va même jusqu à reléguer le président de
la république au rang de premier
ministre vous savez ce que j'ai
également arrêtées l'accord sur
l'environnement de paris j'aime beaucoup
le premier ministre macron mais je lui
ai demandé comment l'accord avancé il
n'y arrive pas vraiment bon on peut
imaginer qu'il s'agit d'une simple
erreur mais connaissant l'attirance de
donald trump pour les pics en tous
genres qui sait
[Musique]
voilà donc une relation entre chefs
d'état qui avait très bien commencé à
première vue et qui à l'aube de
l'élection américaine semble finir en
eau de boudin et dans ce coude à coude
on ne peut pas dire que ce soit emmanuel
macron qui est était mauvais joueur